hello everyone i'm judge jeanine pirro
along with jessica tarlov joey jones
kennedy and greg gutfeld
it's five o'clock in new york city and
this is the five
[Music]
let me start by apologizing my voice
i'm feeling much better than i sound the
president is doing better he slept well
last night
uh he ate his breakfast and lunch
i
fully he actually showed me his plate
didn't ask about the menu but i did see
an empty plate with crumbs
oh my god president biden isolated and
covered jail trying to project
confidence that he is okay after
catching the virus the president's
symptoms are improving after his first
full day of taking the antiviral drug
pexlovin but there's plenty of
controversy the white house being
questioned over why biden's doctor is
not being allowed to talk directly to
the american people things getting
really testy in the briefing room over
that one
yes you have you've heard from the
letter that is hearing directly from him
we're not playing telephone here you're
hearing directly uh from the from the
physician yes it is i mean that's that
is hearing directly uh from in his words
in his words you are hearing directly
from dr o'connor as i read out but i'm
answering your colleagues question here
so
give me the second to do that thank you
and then there's the media we wish the
president a speedy recovery
unfortunately the press wasn't so
gracious back when president trump got
infected
going into crowds uh unmasked and all
the rest was sort of a brazen invitation
for something like this to happen in
large part
it's his own dereliction is um partly to
blame for this he chose to handle this
situation this way i look at this as a
drunk driver who injured himself in a
wreck and killed the oncoming sober
driver donald trump has injured himself
the treatment he's getting at taxpayer
expense is privileged treatment it
angered me he didn't take enough safe
precautions to protect himself
or others i think it would also be a
good idea for him to come out and say
look i have been wrong
fast forward to now
the media is singing a different tune
and praising biden's maskless video
explaining his cova diagnosis
let's remember his predecessor took off
his mask even though it was sort of in
the period where he could have possibly
infected other people he didn't want to
talk about getting vaccinated at the
white house president biden i suspect
just in talking to white house officials
is going to remind people yes i could
get it which means you can get it which
means we all have to be vigilant about
this
okay so what we have is a story of two
presidents
one being
basically condemned it's his fault he
got covered uh and one being praised as
a strong man who's coming through uh uh
this this disease i'm gonna go to you
greg you know when biden criticized
trump he said he didn't take the
necessary precautions to defend himself
how can we expect him to defend the
country now we saw biden he was in
israel he was in saudi arabia he wasn't
wearing a mask yeah the big difference
between joe and donald is
donald is not a super spreader you know
he was a germaphobe before it was cool
right and he never shook hands with
anybody anybody until he had to run for
president and then he had to do it
meanwhile joe biden invades everyone's
personal space he has no id he's like
russia he's like a personal russia
plundering ukraine but it's your
personal space you saw how many people
he touched i mean he's spreading so much
virus hunter biden is jealous
also
we got to point this out i love that
that montage just to see the number of
people who have obvious risk factors
passing judgment on people if you are as
obese as brian stelter you can't go on
there and start criticizing people about
what they're doing about their health
and i'm glad the doctor said he finished
his plate and i hope he went boom boom
after but i don't question the diagnosis
at all i just questioned the timing of
it i mean first you had that wacko
cancer gaffe from two days ago right in
which the media rushed to the defense oh
no he had skin cancer that's not what
we're talking about we're talking about
the fact that he said he got cancer from
oil and uh it made no sense but now you
have polling that shows that he's less
popular than getting punched in the face
so there could be a reason for a lot of
this that they're just trying to hide
him because that's the only thing that
works and perhaps maybe to generate some
sympathy next week they're going to say
you know he has fibroids because as you
know men can get pregnant but you know
the craziest part of it is is not so
much that you know he said that that
that he has cancer and they said yeah he
had skin cancer he said it in the
present tense i had cancer i don't say
in the present tense and the white house
having to go back kennedy and meet and
say we've got to clarify this how can we
trust a president who can't even say
what tense he's in well i don't know
that you can and i know jessica's
supposed to be the democrat on the panel
today but this president is miraculous
we have not given him enough credit
to overcome cancer and coven in a day
i mean he's so healthy he ate a plate of
food and he slept at night uh this is
really wonderful i i just i i could have
completely done a 180 on this president
and i want to vote for him again and
again and again i hope he runs in 30-28
that's how good he is yeah and that's
how healthy is and he's going to last
forever you know why we haven't heard
from his personal doctor
reading a letter
is not hearing from a doctor reading a
letter is reading a letter because you
can't ask a letter questions i have
tried uh when the the former vice
president dan quayle sent me a missive
it would not answer back when i would
talk to it that's one thing uh but the
other thing is ronnie jackson that's why
you're not hearing from his doctor
ronnie jackson because if the press
isn't totally hypocritical they are
going to drill in so hard just like they
did on the former president's doctor
okay so jessica i'll let you answer that
why did we have an epidemio
epidemiologist yesterday answering
questions about the president he works
in the white house but he's not the
president's doctor why and why did you
know it was very telling the way karine
jean-pierre
responded she was very rattled by the
insistence that you're not being
transparent you're not not letting us
talk to a doctor i'd like to say first
of all that kennedy violated the rules
by stealing my talking points while i
was getting my makeup done and coming
out here and giving them yeah um i think
that his personal physician should be
made available i i think that if you did
criticize the past guy for all these
things you remember that dr bornstein
who wrote that ridiculous letter that
then it was admitted that trump dictated
it himself
set a better precedent it's not the end
of the world and people will ask
questions i'm
fairly con 99 certain that joe biden is
in certainly much better health than
president trump was just based on the
fact that he exercises and you don't
think golf is exercising jessica you
offended our audience i don't think that
i did i mean
i watched a little golf last weekend
they look pretty fit but they're
professional athletes versus just people
hanging at their golf course you can't
stop it okay the reason that
the reason that the comparisons between
biden's covet and trump's covet
are quite clear and relevant to be
making is
donald trump got coveted before vaccines
he got them before antivirals it was
very risky there were reports that came
out after thank god he got out of walter
reed the people on his team were scared
he was going to die he was that sick he
also had before he got sick at the
beginning of covid claimed it wasn't
airborne when it was airborne and even
once he did get vaccinated he didn't
want to talk about it because so many
people in his base weren't for it there
was booing at a rally about getting
vaccinated he did not treat kovid nearly
as seriously as president biden did i'm
not taking away credit for operation
warp speech but this was a bad attitude
this is a man who went to the hospital
because he was that sick and then
insisted that the secret service drive
him out to his fans who were waiting for
him while the man had a disease that has
now killed over a million americans it's
a man to the people yes yes
and you know what a gem and people love
the man and they they wouldn't they
would have taken his friends
which is scary it's a whole block but
joey isn't it isn't it interesting how
they can both be on a balcony one's a
killer and one's a hero you know what's
interesting to me is it's so fun for
democrats to to sharp shoot president
trump in every action he made every word
he said how he got covet how he handled
it they love to go back and rewrite
history or at least re-examine president
trump's actions on coven but you won't
hear them criticizing anything about dr
fauci or dr burks or never every single
expert or every single expert that has
been
trumped out there and almost everything
they said was proven wrong within six
months eight months a year so for the
experts that they enjoy it's that hey it
was a moving target we had to figure it
out we didn't know that mask uh we
didn't know that these types of masks
didn't work when since then they've
admitted that they they really did that
so that medical professionals could get
them and regular people wouldn't go buy
them up and all these things you know
everything from doctor from dr fauci
probably funding to the research that
helped lead to this and covering it up
they don't want to re-examine any of
that but they do want to re-examine how
president trump got coveted and you know
the sad fact that he didn't die from it
i guess i'm not really sure don't do
that i don't know
you said it they didn't say you're not
talking
democrats do yeah
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else